moi j'ai deux succès j'ai la chance
d'avoir le succès depuis beaucoup
d'années
je me sens pas seule ne sont pas isolés
j'ai toujours beaucoup d'amis qui sont
les mêmes que ceux de ma jeunesse et il
ya le problème aussi on dit souvent
qu'un acteur peut pas marcher dans la
rue tranquille moi je me balade dans les
rues tranquillement mal avec les gens
font la queue devant mes films
on me fout la paix et pas un espoir
aussi au palais des sports aussi je vais
à la boxe de six ans et demi je veux
maintenant connue depuis longtemps et on
me laisse tranquille peut pas dire que
ça ça a bouleversé ma vie je crois que
si on veut on peut continuer exactement
pareil si on veut se mettre dans une
tour d'ivoire
ça c'est possible on peut se mettre dans
une tour d'ivoire en étant chef
comptable aussi quelque part et je crois
qu'un acteur doit toujours accepter la
critique aussi bien à dison la vraie
critique qui des fois on la trouve
toujours injuste quand on se fait abîmée
c'est ce qui est normal des poils et des
prêts ne l'est pas mais de la lyre c'est
tout juste ans c'est toujours moi
j'écoute toujours mes amis critiques je
reprends ans qui a de grosses cas de
mauvais gestes aussi les gens dans la
rue parce que je crois que si on l'a si
on refuse tout ça c'est alors on est
persuadé qu'on est le meilleur du monde
et injustement arrêtés est ce que cette
lucidité va jusqu'à quand vous regardez
en projection la première mouture d'un
film est ce que vous vous dites là je
crois je me suis trompé j'ai l'épaule au
sein des lions le sang vous le savez et
je crois que l'acteur est toujours assez
instinctif malheureusement il m'est
arrivé je citerai pas de noms mais de
faire un film de qui était très bon sur
le papier par an et puis ils craquent au
milieu et on le sent déjà il nous avait
au oui à l'inversé arrive on sent un peu
le bateau coule et malheureusement on ne
peut on ne peut rien faire et ça se
confirme souvent à la sortie puisque le
public m'aime
jugement vous on essaye de lutter mais
on ne peut pas toujours gagner et pour
celles des fois on vous dit pourquoi
avez-vous paix tel film au départ ils
étaient bons et les mâles arrivée et
d'autres comme vous dites on pouvait
penser bronze ce sera un gentil petit
film et c'est devenu de ce jour pense
pas qu'au départ personne n'aurait pu
penser que abou dessous c'est un très
grand film
il ya d'autres vedettes qui marche bien
en france sans citer de noms vous
connaissez les acteurs comme moi qui
enchaîne film sur film peut-être par
angoisse ou par inquiétude vous ce n'est
pas le cas vous faites quoi un film par
an maintenant au maximum vous est fixé
ce oui oui je sais pas plus parce que
d'abord je dis tant donné que je suis
producteur du film maintenant il ya le
temps de monter le film
après la préparation la sortie tout ça
et il ya aussi que je pense qu'on las le
public si on fait trop de films si vous
êtes 4 5 fois dans l'année sur l'écran
c'est difficile que les gens aient envie
d'aller d'aller vous voir et je pense
aussi qu'on joue mieux quand on joue pas
sans arrêt pressés sur les nerfs on a le
temps de vivre à côté parce que c'est je
crois que le métier d'acteur on parle
toujours de professionnalisme on dit
toujours c'est un grand professionnel
mais faut pas oublier aussi que c'est
surtout des artistes est un art is a
besoin de vie de de rêver un peu moi
j'ai vu le plus bel exemple avec mon
père est un artiste merveilleux qui lui
par contre travaille sans arrêt mais
trahi comme un véritable avec
l'inspiration est normal jean paul
belmondo vous avez beaucoup beaucoup
tourné depuis près de vingt ans il ya
des films
soyez fier dont un peu moins oui sinon
en effet délaissé des roms en forêt au
musée s 15 h en hiver faisant des
pierres oui très fier il s'adressa va
passer à la télévision prochainement
oui oui j'en suis très content parce que
c'est à des films qui m'a fait le plus
plaisir à plusieurs reprises d'abord ce
dp avec jean gabin acteurs que j'admire
depuis mon plus jeune âge d'abord j'ai
un peu dans les ventes
mais tu as eu des moments romain
toujours lb nuit j'aimerais emmener en
andalousie
les nuits sont plus
mais en chine aussi - glissant vers le
sud je pense qu'il faudrait et ben voilà
il humiliait tous appellent tous à lui
plus que la mine verneuil a plus ou
moins tout va bien on dirait des
dialogues superbe puis à blondin et il y
avait blondin aussi que j'ai eu la
chance aussi de connaître à saint
germain des prés autrefois
donc c'est un film pour moi que j'aime
énormément et je pense qui est un grand
film commence si vous voulez à
reconnaître maintenant peut-être
justement ça revient conversation qu'on
avait au début
au départ on a 10 et gabin belmondo
vermeille cdu c'est du tout cuit donc ça
va être facile donc on va le critiquer
et puis on s'était un bon film et qui
n'a pas des situations qu'elle avoue
tout est moche et albert frère
j'espère trouver la ville l'autochtone
en carrière si les premiers
vous avez l'impression avec le recul que
c'était un des tournants de la carrière
certainement c'était un des tournants
parce que vous savez c'est est un
vraiment un rôle très plein très très
riche avec beaucoup de nuances et
beaucoup de choses à faire pour pour un
acteur
et en plus vous savez gabin a joué avec
gabin ça a été pour moi très
enrichissant ya deux acteurs qui m'ont
beaucoup appris je crois à jouer avec
eux c'est pierre brasseur et j'ai eu la
chance de jouer au théâtre pendant sept
mois et je crois que j'ai appris là
puisque en quatre ans le conservatoire
et d'avoir eu la chance de jouer aussi
avec je parle plus on view vous savez on
a aussi quand on a du succès je sais que
c'est parmi les choses et fois qu'on me
reproche on dit belmondo il va être tout
seul je pense que c'est faux parce que
plus on a des acteurs très bons ou des
actrices très bonne en face de soi mieux
en jouant à ce que les gens à qui je
m'entends pas c'est comme ça ça va pas
mais si vous voulez regarder au tennis
vous jouez bien si vous avez un bon
partenaire ils se croient que le cinéma
c'est pareil et moins jeunes c'est à
tort de dénoncer ce qu'on a comme les
nuits nécessaire
[Musique]